this is a model of p4 white phosphorus
which has four phosphorous atoms joined
together as a tetrahedron but you can
see that the bonds are really bent
chemists call them banana bombs because
it looks just like a banana with a bit
of imagination and this makes the
molecule very reactive particularly if
you get the phosphorus finely divided or
you warm it a little it reacts with
oxygen and bursts into flames
one of my colleagues was wearing a tie
you can see wrong nice tie and he got a
bit carried away during demonstration
and spilled a solution of white
phosphorus on the end of his tie and
before the end of the lecture the
solvent had evaporated and his tie
caught fire then you can see a whole
chunk of it has got burnt off
so as the the carbon disulphide
evaporates from the paper well there's a
couple of drips and you can see that the
phosphorous is oxidized in the air and
it's taken some of the paper with it to
generate a nice P for phosphorous just a
little bit of smoke I was really excited
to say I never seen the tide that had
been burnt with phosphorous before so he
gave it to me
provided that I gave him a new tie
instead I've still got to order it the
product from the reaction is this
slightly mysteriously called phosphorous
pentoxide pentoxide means five oxygen
atoms and the reason it's mysterious is
because the molecule actually has 10
oxygen atoms it has four attached one to
each phosphorous and then instead of the
banana bonds you now have an oxygen atom
in between this material is white and
it's great property is that reacts very
vigorously very violently with water to
make phosphoric acid phosphoric acid is
a bit disappointing if you like strong
acids because it's rather weak it
doesn't corrode things very much but if
you breathe phosphorus pentoxide vapor
it reacts with the water in your nose
and your mouth making the acid which is
not at all Pleasant because what you're
seeing is the phosphorus pentoxide on
the side of the flask which is a
phosphorescent compound so it's getting
excited and it's phosphor SE there is a
small amount of phosphorus pentoxide
coming out at the top which is drying
away throat slightly but chemists find
this really valuable compound because if
there's just a tiny trace of water in
something it will react and remove it
now there are many chemicals that react
with water and if you're studying them
the last thing you want is to have a
small amount of water in the solution
that you're doing the reaction in
because your beautiful compound suddenly
reacts and disappears
if you use phosphorus pentoxide it will
get every last drop of water out of your
solvent or whatever you're using so
it'll be really dry so you can do the
chemical reaction just as you want
phosphorus is a very very reactive
element especially this type of
phosphorus which is white phosphorus
phosphorus itself elemental phosphorus
exists is a number of different
allotropes so a bit like carbon with
diamond and graphite and here we have
one of those allotropes it's white
phosphorus many elements exist in
several different forms and phosphorus
is in the same group as a nitrogen
nitrogen exists as n2 molecules with two
nitrogen atoms joined together by three
bombs but phosphorus forms this p4
molecule and you have to heat this up to
several thousand degrees centigrade 18 I
think is 1800 degrees centigrade to get
much p2 in the gas phase you can get
photos you can get p2 but as you go down
the periodic table elements become less
and less likely to form multiple bonds
between them to make p2 or n2 you have
to have three bonds a triple bond
whereas in this molecule the phosphorous
still has three bombs but it's got three
single bonds in terms of the energy of
the molecule p4 is more stable than p2
whereas for nitrogen it's the other way
around
but once you've got single bonds you can
arrange the single bonds in different
ways so you can get different form of
phosphorus called red phosphorous where
instead of having four phosphorus atoms
as a tetrahedron you have six phosphorus
atoms in a ring and because they're not
bent the bonds are not nearly as
reactive in red phosphorus so your tie
wouldn't catch fire with red phosphorous
white phosphorus for many years
has been used in so-called incendiary
bombs these are bombs or shells that are
used in war to set fire to things if you
set fire to somebody's the building
somebody's in there either killed or
they have to leave and the problem with
phosphorus and what makes these bombs so
unpleasant is that as it burns it
liquefies and can stick to people and
set fire to people as well war is always
a horrible thing and killing anybody is
horrible but using white phosphorus can
cause considerable suffering and
particularly when used in areas where
there's civilians it is something which
really is not to be encouraged